hey Michael yeah contractions are coming
every 10 minutes okay just remember to
keep breathing my cervix is ripening
okay good
Jan is about to have a baby with a sperm
donor and Michael is preparing for the
birth of a watermelon with the white now
this baby will be related to Michael
through delusion Michael yeah my waters
breaking okay okay what do you do I get
a call from Jan and I meet her at the
hospital right highways or surface roads
I take Quincy AB to Gibson no Gibson is
covered in potholes your car breaks down
adapt I check the route there are no
problems come on yeah do the
circumstance you're like to have my baby
yes babies are one of my many areas of
expertise growing up I perform my own
circumcision just keep pushing oh babe
right here pushing free mummy up I want
anesthesia no you can't have it it's too
late no I don't want to just push it out
okay keep stimulated yes okay wouldn't
the baby emerges market secretly in a
kind of a mark that only you can
recognize and no baby snatcher could
ever copy ready yes Oh God Wow what was
on that butter newborns are slippery
nice touch good let's try that again I
just going to big the happiest day of my
life
alright let's get started
Scully where are you on digitizing the
old Case Files as of yesterday I'm
officially one percent done why are you
smiling
that's nothing boy there's thousands of
cases and for each one I have to fill
out 200 little box thingies on 50
different screens least you get to sit
on your butt all day that's actually the
worst part my doctor said I have an anal
Canyon Scully why are you always telling
us about your disgusting body I don't
see anything
that's because it's all bored I'm sorry
you guys have probably noticed my
stomach's a little more sensitive lately
so if you wouldn't mind wearing a little
less perfume and if your lunch is
especially pungent maybe have it in the
break room we would really appreciate it
Pam is constantly throwing up because of
the pregnancy if she eats something the
fetus doesn't like she has screwed it's
amazing at 3 ounce fetus is calling the
shots it's so badass
Phyllis um if you could switch to a
different soap just for a month or two
yours is kind of perfume me now this is
getting ridiculous oh gee I'm sorry I
guess I missed the meeting where we all
voted for you to get pregnant no I
reserve the right to peel my hard-boiled
eggs at my desk all morning I look
forward to my afternoon cigars and I am
not stopping for anyway I don't think
I'm asking for too much I guess it's
just the end of courtesy in the
workplace
watching people get sick always makes me
sick and frankly so does talking about
it so Wow vacation the place on the
corner of serving lemonade and heat to
keep the jar it's pretty cool yes that's
very cool Scully mm-hmm will you excuse
me just one moment oh sure
guys guys guys Scully has a mason jar
full of lemonade you called us in here
to tell us that no I called you in here
to change your lives for you see a mere
five minutes ago Hitchcock introduced me
to his new goldfish who lives in Oh
technical mason jar oh this isn't gonna
end well there are two possible outcomes
and we're gonna bet on which one happens
first so will Hitchcock put fish food in
Scully's lemonade or will Skelly drink
Hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade hey
dr. strike is on fish what what's wrong
Michael
you do this just stinks
don't touch it please don't touch it you
got a ton of dandruff okay let me be how
do you go in here what's walking in and
I noticed something shiny under
Stanley's car and I got under see what
it was and I messed up my hair all for a
stupid piece of tinfoil but best case
scenario you thought it was a corner
kill me right now we have peanut butter
in the kitchen I don't feel like peanut
butter give me an ice-cream sandwich oh
not for you it's for your hair and it is
9:00 a.m.
no Dwight not the good peanut butter
people are gonna get mad hey hey hey
this is my hair we're talking about
smells good tastes good too Oh dog
that's disgusting
a lot of calories well just don't leave
it on too long keep massaging please oh
yeah that's nice
we're here to apologize can't prove you
took my Moose Tracks so I should have
yelled at you I'm impressed
it takes a big person to admit when
they're being a total dum-dum we want to
make it up to you
we got your pizza only one pizza for
both of us
oh my god that was an obvious setup you
morons you're eating cheese you're lying
about being lactose intolerant no we
weren't some things are just delicious
enough to suffer the consequences I'm
diabetic but I still eat sugar out of
the bag well just admit you took my
Moose Tracks admit it admit it yeah we
ate it and we're eating your pizza
so who's the [ __ ] now admit it that's
the victory right no Terry there are no
winners here Wow it's a little early for
ice cream oh okay it's never too early
for ice cream Jim well we didn't have
any ice cream so this is mayonnaise and
black olives oh it's a comfort food all
right god this old Donna thing is gonna
be okay you just stop beating yourself
up I know well I hope you're right
we'll see what Dwight says why do we
have to see what Dwight says because I
have him investigating her I'm waiting
for a text Michael no no no no no undo
that undo that it's too late to undo it
I need to know otherwise this thing is
gonna spiral out of a monk Michael okay
I'm I'm going to talk straight to you
because I think you need to hear it oh
this is gross stop eating it do you want
to be happy look at you you have a major
self-destructive streak in you hmm
and you you kind of Torpedo every
romantic relationship you're in that's
not
and I've known some wonderful women
Holly Carroll Jan alene Pauline my
mother
oh my mother Helene oh yeah yes yes yes
all of all of the greatest loves of my
life
you should stop this welcome to the
Jimmy jabs we play for pride we play for
the phone numbers of roses friends but
most importantly we play to watch Amy
lose nope this is my ear
it's my ear too please don't align
yourself with me why not neither of you
have ever come close to winning you're
exactly the same just a couple of
Santiago's but the real prize is the
winchester 3000 the only chair in the
precinct with minimal staining good
lumbar support and no broken Rolly
wheels over to you Gina
thank you Jake okay guys as usual the
loser of each event is eliminated from
the games the winner gets a bonus in the
final round our first event is the mouth
of fawn in front of you is month-old
Chinese food from the fridge go ahead
and eat as much as you can stomach on
your mark get set Wahlberg
oh I can't do this to my mouth she's the
love of my life
Charles is eliminated oh I think that
ball of soup was off
wow I can do this I'm gonna win so bad
oh great here quick
let me take a picture oh that's so cute
you've got a little bit of mold on the
tip here knows I tried I tried but he's
unbeatable
right
you